looking to the stars for economic
salvation that's what semi PS are
seeking in their reports on space
capabilities for European security and
defense it would see European companies
in particular SMEs build and launch
satellites and develop software and
imagery programs yo creo que para yo es
estrategia europea de sobra defensa
basada en la innovación y las newest
technology azenis kappa Gia's pergolas
que ya estamos de cero y ando vassar
clave a para la buena cooperation pero
también desde un puto vista la igualdad
de los or repair facilities also about
ensuring the security of citizens but at
this fear it might be seen as a way to
militarize space Vienna strande mama
targus risotto subject roba da un
certain system Benji nada murni a pro
vespa train struck natomas in near
entered Rodney DOMA Ganesha be on booze
food of an attack Iran Cuba speech in
stock nilesh me bardzo dobrze derelict
optimal nay to Rose's character parts in
the report MEP is colon European
Commission to lay out the groundwork for
a comprehensive European Space policy
you